I think speaking of Bin chickens and our
terrible meals in L.A reminding me of
this I went to Medieval Times oh okay
you know you've seen medieval times do
you ever watch cable guy no the movie
Jim Carrey where's the Cable Guy no it's
a really good trying to explain yeah
right so Medieval Times is this kind of
um this is like a renaissance fair or uh
it's like a pantomime performance where
there's like an arena and there's like
Knights of different colors and this the
the seating areas like a stadium mini
Stadium oh cool it reads into colors and
everyone gets a house color right right
and you sit and you watch the
performance and you get a meal you get
drinks as well
and um yeah so then these dudes come out
in like white red or whatever and they
all do like games to see who's the the
best Knight right and then they have a
fight at the end to the side it's all
choreographed it's all performance and
they all talk with British accents and
some some of the actors nail it and some
of them oh God there's just one actor
who like it sounded like Sylvester
Stallone trying to do a British accent
it was so bad every time he spoke I just
couldn't like I I was because I was with
Emily and dieters I just couldn't stop
laughing yeah and then they would start
laughing because they're like Connor
he's trying his best
so bad he's so bad
um but it was really fun it was
interesting they're really [ __ ] good
at their job yeah I mean yeah it was a
fun performance I thought I was gonna
hate it because I was like ah it seems
really challenging is the meal any good
or oh God knows
so what did you get
I I mean to their credit it was accurate
to the the 1200s
like you don't get a knife and fork
which I'm fine with I'm fine with I just
I didn't know that so when I got a whole
chicken and a garlic bread and the soup
I I was like oh oh I just I just like
grab it I don't think I got a knife how
the [ __ ] are you supposed to eat the
soup you just grab the plate and just
play that or yeah I think so just you
should just cup with your hands yeah
yeah
literally it was all with your hands
because like I remember they gave us
like two moist towelettes and I was like
rationing them while trying to eat this
full like quarter chicken right and
there's no seasoning on this chicken and
this thing was bone dry right bone with
a capital B dry
right no no no no no no the soup was
just tomato soup and it was like the
exact kind of like you know that if it's
a mass manufactured tomato soup that's
the exact taste it was okay can I get
this straight I'm not complaining about
the food because I I expected it to be
good I know that when you go to a Penta
minus thing you're not going for the
food yeah of course but if I could have
like had my an option but he didn't
expect to eat like a peasant an actual
peasant if I could have had an option to
not eat the food and eat somewhere else
I would have done that oh it wasn't even
an option to not have the food no no you
you get the food oh and they gave us
garlic bread bro and I tap this on my
glasses
I don't care I literally don't care I
just thought it was funny at least the
show was good right the show was great
dude they were really whacking each
other with these metal swords because
they were like sparks flying out oh [ __ ]
it was hype as [ __ ] I got really into it
I was screaming yeah
anyway this chicken chicken I was like
nearly I was in like the Sahara Desert
by the end of it I was drinking I had
like a four liter beer as well guess how
much it cost me four four liters it was
like three liter beer I'm exaggerating
three it was a three liter beer still
three liters is what that's like what
that maybe it was it was [ __ ] beer
guess how much it cost me it's uh 20 30
bucks maybe how much do you think about
it I think about 30 bucks yeah it was 35
yeah this beer and I didn't know this
because it wasn't well explained to me
or maybe I'm just dumb I didn't listen
so if you pay 35 American goddamn
dollars for uninclusion tip I I don't
know if I had a chip it was I was just
at a bar it was being like a service
charge or something I think so yeah okay
so apparently you get to then refill
that
oh yes I think you get to keep it I did
I didn't keep it because I didn't know
that but apparently refilled the glass
with beer yeah yeah yeah right well then
that's [ __ ] that's worth it yeah no
no that's all you can drink for 35. for
the refill how much eight or nine bucks
oh that's not too bad right but I mean I
think through three liters of beer in
like an hour and a half show how many
beers can I Chuck bro like that's that
wasn't even the worst though remember
the [ __ ] beer that I bought for
everyone at the [ __ ] Mogul money
yeah and I was just like guys don't
worry I got this one you know I was
feeling good that day I got full like
you know tall boys of beer it was like
96 dollars I was like what the [ __ ] okay
that's fabulous that's a stadium that's
what it is I actually tried to okay
I didn't tell you boys this about what
happens before you bought the beer yeah
because the reason Joey bought all the
beers was because uh to get into this
venue you had to you either had to have
like a a clear bag yeah uh or you had to
like put your bag into storage or or it
was a small bag or it has to be like a
really really small bag like a bomb yeah
so my bag was too big to go into the
security and his bag is Tiny yeah yeah
it was a really really tiny bag
um and so I was like great I'll just put
my bag into storage that's no Pro
problem I'll bring out my credit cards
just in case I need to buy something I
put it in and then only after I go into
security
do I remember oh yeah my ID was in that
bag and I completely forgot to bring my
ID
and so and so we go up we go up and it's
I said it's actually pretty chill right
it's not like we got grilled or anything
like that they just you know they just
asked for ID and so I tried to explain
that you know I didn't have my ID but
I'm [ __ ] 32 okay I'm 32 I forgot my
bag uh I forgot my ID in my bag that's
in a storage case 10 minutes
and so and so they're all like do you
have any kind of form of ID on you that
we can take at all
like and like I look at him then I was
just like
do you uh so this is gonna sound weird
but I have a Wikipedia article
you actually do that did it
worked and they're all like oh are you
serious can I see it and so I load up my
Wikipedia article and I can see this guy
just he he looked at it and he was just
like [ __ ] is this a form of ID I can
actually accept and he actually
considers it for about like a minute or
two and I'm like please guy my guy come
on look I I'm I am actually 32 and he's
just like
oh sorry I don't think I can accept this
but if but if you get someone else to
buy it on your behalf AKA Joe yeah then
then that'll be fine so that's that's
why they allowed Joey to buy it for me
you literally pulled the I'm kind of
famous
like this is the first time I've ever
tried to flex the [ __ ] back yeah okay
okay
put some mileage out of it you know that
I I hope they [ __ ] normalize that
from now on though
like that's photo ID technically your
famousbirthday.com yeah come on my
photos there my birthday's there God I
can't believe that's something I would
do that's a mini thing I was desperate
for a [ __ ] beer okay because I
because the reason is once we went in we
couldn't go back out so there was no way
I would I thought there was no way I
could get a beer for this show and I was
like I can't sit through a [ __ ] three
hour show so but are you kidding me
that's how I'm British of me you know
um
beer was stupidly expensive I paid like
90 bucks for four beers and I'm just
like what the actual [ __ ] that's where
they're making all their money not these
[ __ ] tickets of course of course yeah
I guess I guess the medieval times one
was good in comparison oh yeah we'll
tell you what time was good though good
show it should go sometime it's fine oh
I loved it that sounds really really fun
yeah oh yeah it was surprisingly good
they did that whole thing at the start
of the show where they read out
everyone's birthday and it was like
Timothy uh 11 years old congratulations
I was like oh yeah I'm on a kids thing
technically that's good fun though oh
yeah good good piss up with the boys
yeah hell yeah that sounds fun yeah we
should definitely go next time yeah